Falcon one do we have a go the light is
green Tiger one what are you gonna say
when he crashed through the window hey
there sorry for dropping in goosebumps
Jake goosebumps it's equipment secure
check weapon loaded check did you have
breakfast what that's not on the
checklist I added it because I care
about you no I did not have breakfast
unacceptable look in your pocket hey
there's little chocolate chips in this
yeah I'm not an idiot I know how to
trick my best friend into eating his
fiber all right bar digested mission go
frankly he's a real jerk harsh words but
this reporter does love those t-shirt
cannons now Jen what are your thoughts
about all of this this is not a time for
politics I am calling on Leslie Knope to
cancel all of her campaign events out of
respect for the Newport family anything
else would be a classless move on par
with spray-painting nipples on the
Lincoln Memorial okay emergency meeting
I need everyone to gather around me in
order of how much I trust them here's a
situation a man has died with that hey
buddy got you some of those fish
doughnuts you like so much to cheer you
up
although full disclosure I couldn't find
where they sold them so that's just a
chocolate éclair with LOX on it
oh thanks Jake but I don't need cheering
up you could eat it yourself nope so
what you're not upset about falling hard
for a lady who was immediately thrown in
jail no because she's not actually
guilty they say she robbed her own art
gallery for the insurance money but that
makes no sense she would have made more
if the art had sold this piece
breastfeeding night was worth twice what
she got from the insurance company Wow
look at that
not to sound overly intellectual but
gem-knight boobies is crazy I get art
also I talked to Genevieve's lawyer he's
a total disaster I have a couple
questions about a beautiful client of
yours Genevieve Miren Carter she got hit
by a tow truck and sued the driver you
know she was accused of insurance fraud
oh good cuz I blew that tow truck case
straight I forgot to go to Cork well
they found one of the stolen paintings
in her house but she said she didn't
know how it ended up there she's being
set up framed our joke continued my
hunch is that sad jealous ex-lover girl
like that three dogs makes her own
turkey stock
that's the kind of woman you don't get
over look I know you think my judgments
clouded because I like her a little bit
you doodled your wedding invitation no
that's our joint tombstone fantastic but
as a cop I really don't think that she
did it
something's off about the case okay well
I trust your gut
let's go free an innocent woman nice
dreams are coming true you and me get my
lady off together I mean you know how
that sounds right is the coast clear
what are you wearing I sneak around
close is he gone
yeah he's gone come in you got to see
this Tom and I have been seeing each
other for a few weeks and I think I'm
ready to say I love you to his apartment
I love you so much
look at all these blankets one on the
Ottoman one on the chair one of the
couch your holy hell that soft Oh
oh my god is that yep a whole shelf of
coconut water I think I'm gonna cry this
is like girl heaven did he do all of
this just for you no he just lives like
this he's deeply in debt but you know
what who cares
check it out cheese plate and Adriatic
figs Leslie this is always here I don't
know when he has time to make it
Boutique eye cream unisex cologne lip
exfoliator chocolate-covered almonds and
Sudoku book just amenities everywhere
I love amenities you know check this out
the best part 80 degrees night and day
ah good this one there's another soft
one guard got nauseous so we had to stop
hmm that's weird do you think it's cuz
you're the two most disgusting people in
the universe could be yeah check this
out remember the ex-boyfriend that she
mentioned Nick call mr. Butthead
okay well apparently mr. Butthead just
bought a brand new gallery and Dumbo to
showcase his art which is weird because
Genevieve said he was always in debt
looks like somebody just came into a ton
of money oh and you think she's gonna
want to get back together with him now
that he's rich damn it
no Boyle he probably got the cash from
selling the stolen art your hunch was
right yeah was my hutch my hunch my
lovely KC hunch congi sing with me
I will literally never what you gonna do
with all that hunch all that holds you
inside your brain we're gonna solve this
case solve this case right in your face
we should probably leave this prison yep
hey Leslie what are you doing here why
are you sleeping I just I thought maybe
you'd want to talk more about all the
crazy stuff going on I do I really do
thanks yeah I just got to tell you I'm a
little tired okay so I may have parked
on your front lawn
oh you did I did yeah Leslie and I had
an amazing talk it was so great of her
to come over here even though she was
exhausted beyond belief anyway after we
talked she fell asleep on my couch and
she's been asleep for 22 hours
it's amazing what she slept through at
one point I thought she was up : hi Hey
but then she went right back to sleep
I've been monitoring her vital signs
she's totally fine I love her so much
but I think I'm gonna draw a mustache on
her face hey everyone
sorry I'm late so what's this secret
meeting all about you guys know I'm not
medically cleared for another week it's
not a secret meeting Jake it's an
intervention the tips have to go what
why Jake we're worried about you and you
look very stupid come on guys I think
they're kind of cool retro no they're
terrible Amy come on you're digging the
tips right no I feel like I'm kissing
vanilla ice there was a time you would
have jumped at that chance they have to
go all right you guys got me I did it as
a joke I kept them ironically pretty
funny right it's gonna head out
I'll admit it I went too deep down there
in Florida at one point I think I forgot
where the tip of me ended and the base
of the tips began before we just chopped
them off would anybody like to say some
final words no that was one word that
counts Thank You Rosa okay I'm ready
sorry I'm late everyone but trust me
it's worth it
me and Jake are chip buds you know what
I do see it it's mad it looks bad so
three bedrooms two baths nice big
backyard but no trampoline room correct
correct
like all houses in the world there's no
trampoline room Ben is coming back from
DC in ten days and we are moving into a
house together he would move in my place
but it's a scary nightmare hoarder nest
his words and ants and the official
report filed by the Health Department
I'm just so happy that Ben and I are
starting our life together and my future
is finally back on track Martha I want
to lease this house great thought it was
gonna be more dramatic than that hold on
okay say it again Martha I want to lease
this house
[Music]
Boyle you go through security footage
and see if you can see who brought in
that box okay but I mean I thought since
you were in charge maybe I can be your
right-hand man your Tinker Bell Tinker
Bell let me tell you something Tinker
Bell
Tinker Bell is a loyal tenant and a real
thorn inside Captain Hook I find dunya
my number two yes I made number two I
hear it why would I ever say that let me
just get some details for your file now
are you two a couple no tragically we
are both heterosexual at any rate I
figured we could pass the time and do
something fun maybe a movie night our
options are a bootleg copy of the Diane
Keaton classic something's gotta give
movies hilarious okay surprising opinion
we'll talk about that later and our
second option is surveillance footage of
Detective Amy Santiago soliciting drugs
using perfect grammar it's not that
weird to say may I have some cocaine
it is those options suck fair enough why
don't we have a talent show then who has
a special talent oh I just learned a
single ladies dance Hey yes people love
it look at that two painted ladies just
joined in you got to admit Boyle really
knows how to move his pelvis you came
yeah I had some encouragement your
sweaters on inside out and backwards
it's been a tough morning lots of regret
and shame should be the official slogan
for snakejuice
well this committee would like to ask if
you are the kind of candidate who could
forgive someone after they behaved like
a complete jackass this candidate could
especially because this candidate also
behaved like a total jackass please
don't worry about it the committee
totally understands also I can talk
about my qualifications for this
position but first I am gonna go throw
up in a wastebasket would you mind if I
joined you not at all
you